a new round of extreme weather is
causing trouble for people across the
country today multiple tornadoes tore
through Texas and Louisiana overnight
leaving hundreds of thousands of homes
and businesses without power this is the
same storm that dumped all that snow in
California and it is headed east Janet
shamlian is in Shreveport Louisiana
Janet good morning
Vlad good morning to you these storms
came through here so quickly last night
take a look at this laundromat behind me
there were people inside at the time and
there were children in one of the cars
parked out front where the debris came
down fortunately no one was hurt but it
made for a very rough night here
tornado crossing the road right in front
of us this is the moment a tornado
ripped through Winnsboro Texas last
night and we had to bring in the air
sending splintered scraps from torn
apart buildings hundreds of feet into
stormy skies
Storm Chaser captured another tornado as
it battered the town of Picton east of
Dallas damaging five homes wow
similar site in many communities across
Texas and Louisiana
this is Little Elm Texas where at least
six cars and trucks were buried under
bricks metal beams and other debris when
devastating winds collapsed a shopping
center it just was like a boom
it was on us we got tornado on the
ground in the Dallas area wind gusts as
high as 80 miles an hour Downing power
lines and plunging hundreds of thousands
into the dark
at least 30 people were forced from
their homes in this Hearst apartment
complex after wind tore the roof off a
building
the only thing I hear in the top of the
house is going back everywhere
and in Box Springs Gus reached 70 miles
per hour destroying an Amazon hub no one
was hurt
here in Shreveport search and rescue
efforts underway after a reported
tornado destroyed several businesses
total chaos wind I mean glass breaking
out everywhere first first tornado I've
ever been in
the first round of storms came in here
at dusk the second round closer to
midnight the most dangerous time when
it's dark so Gail for a lot of people
they won't get a look at the damage
until later this morning
Gail
it's going to be tough to see thank you
very much Janet